[Music]
I started my career studying auctions
and marketplaces and in 2007 I was
invited by Microsoft to come in and be
the consulting chief economist and I
started working on the search engine
when I saw what the search engine really
was that it was this huge artificial
intelligence machine learning system
full of lots and lots of algorithms and
a system of testing and incremental
innovation and experimentation that just
captured my imagination in a way that
was even bigger than the problems of
marketplaces that I started with and so
after a few years of doing that I
refocused in academics and I had this
insight that everything I had seen
inside the search engine was going to
transform both academia and business so
it was a really interesting phenomenon
to study just what what will be the
impact of all of this machine learning
technology on the way business works but
also on the way that science works so I
think it's just a new paradigm and so I
saw that paradigm in the commercial
private sector you're making changes
that are affecting you know millions and
millions of users that's exciting but
it's also can feel tough when you look
out and see all these problems in the
world and you think we'll wait is that
really the very best use of my time and
so I think it was really exciting to me
to think about being able to do both
things at the same time to get that
exhilaration of creating products and
evaluating products and doing innovation
that affect a lot of people and do them
for social impact
there's always a huge challenge of the
cost-benefit analysis and whether we can
really afford to provide services to
those who need them the advent of the
mobile phone has given us two things
first of all for people it gives them
the opportunity to use time that would
otherwise be on utilized to get
information to be educated to be trained
and to access services really a lot of
services can be delivered digitally or
interacting over a mobile device so
there's this opportunity to reach people
at a time that's convenient for them
which is really important for people who
are working hard and really stretched
then a second big opportunity is that we
can create services and there can be a
fixed cost of creating a software
product but if the if the services are
delivered digitally if they're delivered
through software then the marginal cost
of providing those services is very very
low if we can find things that work to
help the poor we can actually distribute
them very widely we can distribute them
globally and that's a really big new
opportunity and then a third insight
here is that the tech firms have
actually come up with a new way to do
innovation that's really quite different
than the old way the old way would might
be you come up with an idea you create a
product or service you build it you go
out and test it it's gonna take a lot of
time to see if it works the way that
software products innovation works is
that especially if it's delivered
digitally
and it's a service that people are
interacting with daily is that you can
start with a basic version that might
not work very well but then you test it
and test it every day you make it better
and better every day
it adapts to the scenario and you you
learn from the data about how the
product works and make it better and
better this digital approach allows us
to iterate much faster and in addition
if you can actually personalize things
you can make much much stronger choices
like there might be things that would be
very cumbersome and annoying if you were
a native English speaker that might be
really helpful if you're not a native
English
if you start personalizing and
customizing and adapting to the
individual then you can make choices
that would definitely not be the right
choice in a one-size-fits-all but
they're really much more effective for
the individuals so this emphasis on
personalization is is really an
outgrowth of the machine learning
technology and so our goal is in my
research group is to try to bring all of
those technological innovations that are
happening inside of Amazon and Google
and Facebook and so Microsoft and so on
and actually teach them to these social
impact startups and really help them
learn to to make products that are
beneficial to the poor and that are very
effective
there's two ways to engage with this
this idea of bringing technology
innovations the poor one is to work with
large for-profit companies that have a
very large user base and try to convince
them to put more emphasis on the social
impact side these large companies
actually already have large consumer
bases and they already have a lot of
infrastructure so if you can get them to
adapt that can be impactful for a large
set of people one of our projects is
working with a large tech company to
help induce consumers to give to charity
doesn't get in the way if it doesn't
annoy consumers then the company's going
to be more likely to scale it the larger
set of our efforts here are to partner
with smaller tech companies so tech
companies that are creating training
products that are creating educational
experiences for poor students those
firms are often working with a
shoestring they often don't have a very
large staff they don't have a lot of
machine learning experts and data
scientists on staff but here at Stanford
we have thousands literally thousands of
students who want to learn data science
skills and who are really passionate
about trying to use those skills in a
way that's beneficial for the world so
we're playing a bit of a matchmaking
service between these small social
impact firms and the amazing amounts of
human capital we have here at Stanford
how could we not take advantage of the
ability to make such a big impact on the
world while educating our students
for me the research on causal inference
understanding cause-and-effect using
artificial intelligence to make
decisions that's very inspiring to me
and that's a big part of my research
agenda
the second area focus is really building
artificial intelligence systems that
augment humans that help humans and so
if we think about the pure commercial
incentives of a firm they have to worry
about the bottom line here at Stanford
we can put a lot of emphasis on the
augmenting humans part and really we can
do some of the basic are indeed that
will make it cheaper and easier for
firms to take the next step into
applications when we use AI to help
humans so using AI to educate and train
workers to help workers do jobs that
might have previously required very
expensive education and training but
using AI to help them get the
information they need in the moment so
that a less educated worker can
accomplish a task if you think about
trying to understand the optimization of
delivery routes or of inspector
allocations again this is something that
can be done with data the data can
predict traffic patterns and you can use
software to optimize those types of
scheduling problems another application
is in terms of workers you could use
video footage of customer service
workers and then have humans watch those
videos and label them this was a good
interaction or a bad interaction then
you could train an algorithm to look at
all the video footage and then based on
the algorithm it would say oh this looks
like it was a good one this was a bad
one
what you could do with that is you could
take the ones that were flagged as bad
and then have a human review those and
see okay this is a mistake is it a false
positive or is it really a problem and
if it's really a problem then you could
train that worker on better tactics of
course we have to think about what are
all the things that can go wrong right
you're surveilling your workers in some
way how do people feel about being
surveilled all the time what if somehow
the algorithms tended to score women
worse than men maybe the high voices
were associated with problems and that
tended to flag when
more so there's lots and lots of issues
around worker protection and the the
fair use of the technology that need to
be addressed a firm might not even
realize that they were building biases
into their evaluation metrics unless
they actually had a pretty sophisticated
scientific perspective about how they
were building these systems and that's
where I think some of the research
becomes very important most firms don't
want to have racist and sexist
algorithms that's just a headache for
them but they don't necessarily know how
to build algorithms that aren't so the
great opportunity is that we can
actually build fairness into algorithms
in a way that we can't always force in
humans but you have to be intentional
about it and so that encompasses
everything from understanding the impact
of a I on the work force on an equality
and understanding where frictions are
likely to be important and where maybe
everything will be fine in the markets
will take care of things also thinking
about issues like privacy security
surveillance discrimination bias this is
also a very important role for a
university to play because we can be
thought leaders we can focus on areas
where really society needs to weigh in
the society has to decide how do we feel
about surveillance how do we feel about
who has our data and why I think
everyone who's working in the area of
artificial intelligence is very aware
that this technology is dual-use you
know it can be used for good it can be
used for warfare it can be used for
terrorism what I believe is that by just
educating and getting everyone involved
in the conversation early is our best
that our best hope of mitigating
consequences
I think there's a few big buckets of
opportunity one is just delivering
services more efficiently and conserving
your resources so especially for city
governments you spend a lot of time
sending out inspectors to make sure that
you know electrical wiring is good you
got to fix your potholes and make sure
that those street lamps are working and
so ai and data can be used to make that
dramatically more efficient you can
identify problems much more quickly you
can prioritize the highest risk
circumstances and allocate your your
people to the highest risk scenarios you
can allow people to do much more
self-service you can do the scheduling
much better so people want to sit around
all day and wait for an inspector to
show up you can actually make it clear
to your citizens how you're doing and
help provide good incentives for all of
your service providers by making the
citizens see right away hey how long are
the lines at the DMV and you know how
long do you have to wait for an
inspection and just having that
information can then put the required
pressure on the organizations to improve
their service one project that we're
looking at is understanding the the
programs that are used to help
unemployed workers and provide
retraining services and so we're trying
to use data to understand which programs
are most effective for which types of
people in order to both get people
allocated to the right programs but also
to help the programs know who their
target customer really should be and how
they can improve their service to them
so this is a really exciting moment to
be doing research about digitisation
it's an opportunity for innovation it's
also an opportunity for science because
it's a chance for us to learn what works
and what works exactly right for a
particular person in a particular place
in a particular time at scale in a way
that just has never been possible before
and it's it's just a huge privilege to
be at Stanford at this time to be able
to try to take advantage of that
opportunity
[Music]
you